[Music]
Toby thinks national anthem is going to
brainwash me to what so proud also a
horror movie starts off with some really
scary music cliche from what I
understand about the making of this
movie we're going to have to consult
Maury Povich about its parentage movie
immediately makes you disobey your
mother about sitting too close to the TV
obvious Sony TV makes me remember
product placement has been around since
long before 1982
architect realized on the day of
building that he designed this loopy
staircase while drunk but said maybe
their Dali fans this girl was so tired
she fell asleep in bed on top of some
delicious potato chips and it looks like
she didn't break even one dog's journey
through the house is basically to
introduce all the characters in the
movie nailed down one of the first rules
of screenplays and makes it field happy
Star Wars toy lineup coolness undone by
Rams helmet I think every movie
Spielberg was involved with in the early
to mid 80s required a shot of kids on
bicycles riding around in their
neighborhood
in fact this movie came out one week
before ET so people must have thought
they wanted it at the same movie one
week later kids with remote-control cars
or dicks - hilarious beer toting bicycle
guys this is an orgy of evidence that
Star Wars exists wow this motherfuckin
is the original Star Wars poster
whatever happens to him in this movie he
still comes out on top because that's
how remotes work even in 2015 I can't
get some remotes to work without
directly pointing it at the source so in
1982 this is some incredible bullshit
also this happens every time the
neighbors are watching something at the
same time I would have been tired of
this after one instance but they seem
content on remote control wars also
remote control measuring contest Dyanne
flushes the toilet before throwing the
bird in there so that Caroline can catch
her in the act
also bird flushing bird funeral older
sister with no respect for bird funerals
somehow decides to attend bird funeral
this kid is a future reason why Joss
Whedon left Twitter also Star Wars
Marvel properties poltergeist this will
be due back in 1982 what 2015 would look
like thunder and lightning indicate
something ominous is coming cliche
mother nature cooperated with the
filming of this movie by planting the
world's scariest fucking tree ever right
outside this kid's window that is
definitely the poster for alien and I
now nominate these parents for worst
parents ever for letting their kid even
see that shit at this age you know I
love this kid is into everything soccer
basketball Star Wars skateboarding
helicopter things and even spelling you
know what
over the goldfish they grow up to be bad
science creepy ass clown is already way
creepy before the lights even get turned
out because that thing doing here movie
finally addresses the crazy Carolyn did
10 minutes ago
kids never drape clothing over lit lamps
fire hazard 101 yeah there was pretty
much no reason to keep this bastard
sitting in a chair before bedtime so now
you pay the price
Robbie wasn't raised to understand that
only virgin sacrifice can send clowns to
hell
Wow this family hates this kid
everything about his room is designed to
scar him for life
I mean a Bram's element just when you
think all the Star Wars memorabilia has
been shown
Robbie manages to try to ward off evil
with a previously unseen Chewbacca
jacket these parents smoke pot and
engage in foreplay with the door wide
open this kid just stands here
eavesdropping instead Hey
look looks like a hummingbird the kids
scared of the storm can't you at least
close the damn drapes even though his
daughter is wrong to be on the phone
right now dad opens the door to his
teenage daughter's room without knocking
so the sin is really on him right kids
also I hear it's easier to get kids to
sleep if you give them a contact bus how
can the station be signing off now since
its 237 in the morning although we hear
that the 237 is possibly a reference to
room 237 in the shining
but these ghosts would have to be
amazing Cupid fans to pull that off damn
if it weren't for the fact that these
people left their TV on at night they
would never witness the paranormal
activity the static caused a strobe
light effect oh that escalated quickly
ghosts that travel through TV sets
decide to beam in to random spot on the
wall because I guess it looks cool
anyway thank God for this family's
wasteful electricity negligence huh
famous line is also a famous use of the
pronoun game gene Shalit who did you
mean who's here damn you waited until
the next morning to ask that damn
question 20 minutes you're already late
babe just try and realize the truth that
there is no fork or spoon that works too
movies are to be believed all
construction workers in the like are
catcalling dickheads even two girls who
were 16 although the actress is 22 so
maybe he's just confused but still what
the fuck mom witnesses contractors
sexual harassment of daughter and smiles
with pride when she flips them off but
does not reprimand said contractors oh
yes much better now she'll be blinded by
war movies instead of static borrowed
Wilhelm scream as we see here Paranormal
Activity didn't start this ghost playing
practical jokes fire but it's still a
curious thing for ghosts to waste time
do it this camera movement doesn't lie
so I know some crazy she's about to
happen and there we go chair stacking
classic dick ghost behavior also ghost
try scaring the family by demonstrating
balancing superiority Pizza Hut went to
die and figure this out let chairs were
stacked on the table in the previous
scene and they let the kitchen because
that's scary but then she decided to go
back in play around and manage to find a
ghost hotspot wife is excited about
haunting this fucking ghosts are
borderline useful at this point the
tickling calls you and all students like
there's nowhere except that you can
breathe and you're getting pulled along
at me whoa what the cabin there did the
ghost of the movie also edit this thing
or was the movie saying yeah yeah we get
it you crazy loon let's just
fast-forward to the next scene
ghosts are now commanding the tree
outside to do their dirty work and holy
Sh carol-anne sleeping with that evil
clown doll I guess you guys were begging
for something bad to happen tonight
luckily for the spirit world both
parents and the older sister run away to
check on Robbie leaving five-year-old
Carol Ann by herself
1982 Nadeau not a real girl hanging on
to the headboard it's not a real girl
thanks Dana yeah thank god she's only
missing rope everybody runs out of the
room as Robby stands there muddied and
bloodied and psychologically damaged
cool shot but the odds of this robot
being thrown out of the closet and
landing on his feet and being wound up
are astronomical
and nothing else important happened that
night just Diana my wife she's 31
that's 32 all the Stoddard day now she's
16 Wow you knocked up your wife when she
was 16 how old were you that's I mean no
wonder the ghosts came after your family
am i right ghosts really want this
family out of a house but locate all
their energies in one room that is
easily ignore bulge us by shutting the
door also after taking Carol Ann when
did they start this back up the room
became completely calm after they sucked
her into the closet so why did they feel
the need to get that party started again
also these ghosts kidnapped a little kid
and they're still being dicks this Darth
Vader poster was clearly pulled off the
wall in the previous scene but now it's
back this means either the parents took
the time to put it back up in a room
they're frightened of or the ghosts did
it because you don't have to be living
to enjoy Star Wars meanwhile this alien
poster has been mostly unfazed during
this whole process because it seems
scarier well you can't expect us to send
the time period hamstrung CGI Canyon yes
yes you can that's a whole grinding a
horse right there huh special effects
protractor is so much work so weak the
passage of time has been days even weeks
they haven't called the cops and four
days they just sat around doing nothing
until they called the pre Ghostbusters
the determination as to whether your
home is haunted is is not very easy
ghosts have a sense of humor but also
steal kids it might very well be a
poltergeist intrusion roll credits
they'll be two more in a couple of
seconds they always travel in pairs but
with the first one and two more doesn't
that make a triplet instead of a pair
Oh sweetpea hello sweet pea time to turn
this lamp off for some reason
ghost orders this somebody decided to
wait for days maybe weeks to come after
Carol Ann just in time for the
paranormal investigators to witness it
why does she as soon Caroline was
playing when she disappeared did the
family not tell her that she was
abducted while their son was getting
swallowed by a possessed tree I think
once paranormal investigators are called
were past the point of the story being
unbelievable Wow six minutes of
whispering sure sure and they also
stacked kitchen chairs for no reason and
they create areas of sliding
transportation for anger management well
I think it's about time for more
publicity for the frito-lay company if
you're going to hire ghost experts at
least hire the ones that take their job
seriously
excessive paranormal snack break this
guy's already a dick for raiding the
family's fridge but he's taking out a
porterhouse right they're elevating his
status to more evil than the ghosts oh
good and he's gonna pan-fry it which
will smoke up the entire house and wake
everyone up he's actually as stupid as
he is evil this is not so much a
reflection of paranormal activity as it
is the effects of eating an entire bag
of Cheetos in one sitting or the ants in
this house get to work quickly allmovie
ghosts have a contractual obligation to
put people for an inordinate amount of
time before killing them mostly to
ensure each movie makes its runtime you
gotta love those 1980s makeup effects
turning people into obvious rubber the
Terminator would do this two years later
which makes me think the Terminator
actually got sent back to 1982 first
before it corrected its time-travel
coordinates still prefer this to most
CGI though okay everything's back to
normal it was all a hallucination wait a
minute did he also hallucinate the
bottle of 409 because it's now a bottle
of fantastic hell everything in this
room changed these ghosts have very
detailed and specific hallucinations
plotted out the spirits on this movie
clashed with the cinematographer on
where the camera should be pointed
during scenes
it caused a hostile work environment but
sometimes masterpieces happen despite
the turmoil also why does this camera
need to move when there are two cameras
already pointed at the stairs
I think prima donnas man
I hear this guy trained that girl
working at the cafe and Harry Potter in
the Deathly Hallows Part 1 don't mind me
folks just making a movie with your
video camera inside every spirit is a
dream a dream that he or she will be the
next Spielberg
well somebody saw Raiders of the Lost
Ark and sea Spirit's obviously moved the
dog from the back seat to the front seat
and the taxi driver was not the least
bit scared by it okay but I never
learned our phone number so is the
kitchen fine now
it was the most haunted place in the
house earlier so much so they never
wanted to go back to it and it caused
one of the investigators to freak out
just last night but now here's a casual
breakfast in the kitchen like nothing
ever happened a flask in the coffee mug
switch hands between shots amazing more
ghost hijinks no doubt yeah but I bet
you're still bogarting on the pot
upstairs why does he try to hide the
ghost activity from his boss even the
ass holiest of bosses would have to
believe a piano moving itself is reason
enough to miss work for a few days right
Jesus it's not ancient tribal burial
grounds it's just and there you go
they built Steve's house on a tribal
burial ground and the ghosts got pissed
question though why didn't any of this
affect the other houses built on the
same burial ground Legend of Zelda
that's the room my son and daughter used
to occupy we believe it's the house yeah
but only one of those rooms is throwing
a spiritual rager 24/7 so back off with
your condescension Sutton psychic lady
[Music]
as a Christian sure I think I can do
that they must pass through this
membrane we find out that there's an
evil ghost using Carol Anne to prevent
the other ghosts from crossing over but
I want to know what this has to do with
being a dick to the furniture and why
hitter they set up a kitchen slip and
slide and why enter they made that one
do to hallucinate ripping his own face
off thank you
yeah her master's voice that's racist I
don't know what hovers over this house
why not you know every other damn thing
that's happening in the spirit world
right now you can't figure out this
place was built on a tribal burial
ground yeah as much as we're ripping on
this movie out of pure joy I must say
that the thought of an evil ghost
pretending to be a kid and using Carol
Ann to prevent other ghosts from moving
on is actually a really scary thought
and then now let's go get your daughter
line it's awesome I will remove five
cents because this movie deserves it it
does not deserve to be remained because
it's freaking awesome okay but why
doesn't any of this that was in the
bedroom come through the portal I don't
see any beds or furniture or Star Wars
posters coming through that thing spirit
world softball
how do you know that does never talk to
strangers work in the spirit world
obviously not since she made friends
with the evil ghost on the other side
[Music]
how do you know that
and I'm thinking after all this is over
they're moving up from weed to hard
drugs unnecessary orders oh damn they
managed to do everything wrong and still
get Caroline out your neighbors cheeky
way to say I'm not a virgin anymore is
definitely not something you'd say in
front of your mom unless you had that
kind of relationship which they clearly
don't because she instantly changes the
subject I was there all sorts of here
and there sleeping in the house after
they had that huge moving truck here
earlier in the morning and I thought
they were staying at the Holiday Inn
tonight why is this dickhead still here
and being propped up on a chair facing a
child trying to go to sleep oh well that
didn't work
nothing else I can possibly do to
prevent this clown from looking at me
time to go to bed choking hazard yep you
see this is why you don't allow clowns
in your home this was bound to happen
whether they were in a poltergeist or
not also why was fan genus such a liar
about this house being clean
she clearly has psychic powers so how
did she miss this well someone saw the
Exorcist or Lucy how did this kid rustle
away from the demon when the demon
clearly had the upper hand and as a
demon
why did it close the door if it needs to
get into the kids bedroom has anyone in
a movie ever properly died from falling
down a flight of stairs cuz I don't
think so
yep these are real skeletons folks movie
doesn't follow its own advice about the
death illusion is great for the film but
obviously worthless in keeping Diane
from running to the door what happened
to all that electric shock stuff you
were doing earlier demon portal makes me
think dirty thoughts what I should be
concerned about the family's well-being
in addition to being built on a tribal
burial ground house was also built on
the raddest laser tag arena on the
planet why is it just this house that
got affected because it's an emergency
you suddenly he doesn't know which
pocket he keeps his keys in thankfully
the daughter's boyfriend drops her off
just as the family is skipping out few
family dog is serene during all this
screaming the scene is iconic for sure
but I'm wondering why the ghost took so
long to finally do this the Freeling
family has lived here for years and they
were moving so I don't understand why
they chose this particular day to film
the house into another dimension
neighbors decide and what's the worst
that could happen to us if we get a
closer look funny but we all know the TV
was not the damn problem with your house
it's not ancient tribal burial ground
besides we've done it before
[Music]
do not try and bend the spoon that's
impossible
you know what happens over food goldfish
the same thing that happens to
everything else
[Music]